Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Harold, eldest in birth as in wisdom, was by the king's favor appointed to the earldom in his father's place. In the strength of his body and mind, he stood forth among the people as a second Judas Maccabeus, a true friend of his people and his country. He wielded his father's powers even more actively and walked in his ways, that is, in patience and mercy and with kindness to men of goodwill.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。哈罗德，无论在出生还是智慧上都是长子，受国王恩宠，接替了他父亲的伯爵之位。他身心强健，在人民眼中仿佛第二个犹大·马加比，是他的人民和国家的真正朋友。他比以往更积极地行使他父亲的权力，并践行他父亲的道路，即保持耐心、仁慈，对心地善良的人怀有善意。
But disturbers of the peace, thieves and robbers, this champion of the law, threatened with the terrible face of our lion. Well practiced he was in endless fatigues and doing without sleep and food, and endowed with mildness of temper and a more ready understanding. He could bear contradiction well, not readily revealing or retaliating, never, I think, on a fellow citizen or compatriot. Indeed, the fault of rashness or levity is not one that anybody could charge against him. Sir Tom Holland, the name of this paragon, this patriotic icon.
但对于和平的破坏者、小偷和强盗，这位法律的捍卫者则用我们雄狮般可怕的面容威胁他们。他经受过无休止的劳顿，习惯了忍饥挨饿，并且生性温和，有着敏锐的理解力。他能很好地承受异议，不会轻易显露或报复，我想，他对同胞或同乡更是从未如此。事实上，任何人也无法指责他有鲁莽或轻率的毛病。托马斯·霍兰爵士，这位完美典范、这位爱国偶像的名字。
Dominic Sandbrook. This hero. This enduring hero of the English people, a man worthy to stand as England's last trueborn king. It is of course Harold Godwinson, Earl of Wessex, the man who falls at the Battle of Hastings. And last time we were talking about Duke William of Normandy, the villain of this story. And today we're on somebody who I've always held a candle for. Held a candle for. They held a candle for exactly.
多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。这位英雄。这位英国人民不朽的英雄，一个配得上做英格兰最后一位纯血国王的人。他当然就是韦塞克斯伯爵哈罗德·戈德温森，那个在黑斯廷斯战役中倒下的人。上一次我们聊到了诺曼底公爵威廉，这个故事里的反派。而今天我们要聊的是一个我一直很支持的人。一直很支持的人。他们一直很支持，没错。
Exactly. Do you see yourself reflected in his character and his prowess? The terrible face of a lion endowed with mildness of temper and a ready understanding he could bear contradiction. Well, I mean, it's all adding up. It's all there, isn't it? Yeah, it's absolutely uncanny. It's uncanny.
没错。你觉得他的性格和风范里有你的影子吗？雄狮般可怕的面容，生性温和，有着敏锐的理解力，能承受异议。我的意思是，这全都合上了。全都在这儿了，不是吗？是的，真是惊人的相似。太神奇了。
So this is actually from a biography of Edward the Confessor, not of Harold. That's right. So Harold is a supporting character in this book. Yes. A lot of what we know about the reign of Edward, who was crowned at the end of the last episode and goes on to be called the Confessor, not because he's rushing around confessing to things all the time, which is what people often think. It's because there are multiple Edwards and people haven't yet worked out that you could
所以这段话其实出自《忏悔者爱德华传》，而不是关于哈罗德的。没错。所以哈罗德在这本书里只是个配角。是的。我们对爱德华统治时期的很多了解——他在上一集的末尾加冕，后来被称为“忏悔者”，不是因为他整天跑去向人忏悔，人们经常这么想。而是因为当时有多个爱德华，人们还没习惯用
call them the first, the second, the third or anything like that. I think this is a much better way of doing it. I agree. So Alfred the Great Son was called Edward. So he's Edward the Elder. And then we had Edward the Martyr. And Edward the Confessor is someone who is a saint but hasn't been martyred basically. Right.
第一、第二、第三之类的方式来称呼他们。我觉得这是一种好得多的命名方式。我也这么觉得。所以阿尔弗雷德大帝的儿子叫爱德华。所以他是长者爱德华。然后我们有了殉道者爱德华。而忏悔者爱德华基本上是一个成为圣人但没有殉道的人。没错。
Or that bloke Harold Harefoot. I mean, if you make up a nickname later if necessary. Yes. Brilliant. But that passage that you read comes from a life of Edward the Confessor. Yeah. Probably written in the immediate aftermath of his death early in 1066 and almost certainly commissioned by his queen, who is a woman called Edith, and who just happens to be the sister of Harold.
或者那个叫赤足哈罗德的家伙。我的意思是，如果有必要，以后再编个绰号。没错。太棒了。但你刚才读的那段话出自《忏悔者爱德华传》。是的。大概写于他1066年初去世后的直接余波中，几乎可以肯定是他的王后委托编写的，这个女人叫伊迪丝，而她刚好是哈罗德的妹妹。
So you can see that this is certain. I think these are pretty objective people to be fair. Well you say that, except that Harold is not the only member of his family to be praised in the life of King Edward, because there is also his younger brother, Tostig Godwinson. And Tostig, like Harold, is is an Earl and he's described in the life of King Edward as a man endowed with very great and prudent restraint. Although occasionally he was a little overzealous in attacking evil and with bold and inflexible constancy of mind. And we will see in due course today whether that is a fair description
所以你可以看出，这肯定……我觉得坦白说这些人相当客观。你这么说倒也罢了，不过在《国王爱德华传》中受到赞扬的戈德温家族成员可不止哈罗德一个，因为还有他年轻的弟弟托斯蒂格·戈德温森。和哈罗德一样，托斯蒂格也是一位伯爵，在《国王爱德华传》中，他被描述为一个拥有伟大而审慎克制力的人。尽管有时他在打击邪恶时显得稍有过热，且意志坚定、毫不妥协。今天我们随后就会看到这种描述是否公允
or not. Okay. So we're talking today about this family, the Godwinsons who we left out of the previous episodes, which we wanted to do them all today. And they're obviously massive players in the story of 1066, because we've already had three members of the family. We've had Harold, we've had Tostig and we have had Edith and behind them, Harold, we've had Tostig and we have had Edith and behind them, hence the name Godwinson, is this bloke Godwin, who is not massively well known I would say in English history today but is a titanic figure in English history in the 11th century. So tell us a bit about Godwin and why his name carries such significance to people in
。好吧。所以我们今天要聊的是这个家族，也就是我们在前几集里漏掉的戈德温森家族，我们想今天把他们一次性讲完。他们在1066年的故事中显然是举足轻重的巨头，因为我们已经提到了这个家族的三个成员。我们有哈罗德，我们有托斯蒂格，我们还有伊迪丝，而在他们身后——哈罗德、托斯蒂格和伊迪丝的身后，这也是戈德温森这个名字的由来——就是这个叫戈德温的家伙，虽然他今天在英国历史上可能算不上家喻户晓，但在11世纪的英国历史中，他可是一个泰斗级的人物。那么给我们讲讲戈德温吧，以及为什么他的名字对
the 11th century. Well, he is an astonishing example of social mobility, and he's a classic example of how, in periods of chaos and change and disaster for lots of people, some can find opportunity. And so, to look at how he emerges to this astonishing position of predominance in England, we need to go back to 1016, the conquest of England by Knut and the Danes and the consequence of Knut's triumph is not just the toppling of the Kyrgyz Kingas, the traditional ruling West Saxon dynasty, but also the replacement of large numbers of English elder men, the guys who are in charge of the kind of the various counties and
11世纪的人具有如此重大的意义。好吧，他是社会流动性一个令人惊叹的例子，也是一个典型的例子，说明在充满混乱、变革以及对许多人来说堪称灾难的时期里，有些人如何能找到机遇。因此，要了解他是如何崛起并在英格兰占据这一惊人的显赫地位的，我们需要回到1016年，克努特和丹麦人征服英格兰，而克努特胜利的结果不仅是推翻了传统的西撒克逊统治王朝——基尔盖·金加斯，还导致了大量英国的埃尔德曼（即负责英格兰各个郡和
regions in England by Danish yarls or Earls as they come to be anglicized. But there is one Englishman who is appointed to a position of high rank by Canute early in his reign. And I'm quoting here from the life of King Edward, a man judged by the King, most cautious in council and active in war and this is Godwin who is simply an obscure thane from Sussex. He has no real pedigree at all and in fact his father had been reigned by Aetherred on a charge we're not sure exactly what and he's very cross about this and he commandeers 20 ships from Etherred's fleet and basically
地区的官员）被丹麦雅尔（Jarls，后来被英语化称为伯爵）所取代。但在克努特统治初期，有一位英国人被任命为高级职位，我这里引用《国王爱德华传》中的话：一个被国王认为在议事时最为审慎、在战争中最为活跃的人。这就是戈德温，他最初只是萨塞克斯的一个出身低微的瑟恩（thane）。他根本没有什么真正的门第背景，事实上，他的父亲曾因一项罪名遭到埃塞尔雷德的惩罚——我们不确定具体是什么罪名，他对此非常愤怒，于是他从埃塞尔雷德的舰队中劫走了20艘船，基本上
he kind of turns Viking. He goes off kind of raiding the south coast of England. Right. And it may be that this is how Godwin meets Canute that because he's essentially turned Viking maybe he meets the real Vikings. Maybe Canute recognizes a kindred spirit. But certainly once Canute has become king, Godwin's rise is astonishingly rapid. So in 1020, Knut, who up until that point had been serving as Earl of Wessex himself, you know, he's got a large empire to rule, so he doesn't really want to shoulder that burden. So he gives it to Godwin, who becomes Earl of Wessex. Also,
他就变成了维京人。他开始在英格兰南部海岸进行劫掠。没错。也许戈德温就是这样认识克努特的，因为他本质上变成了维京人，所以他可能遇到了真正的维京人。也许克努特从他身上认出了同类。但可以肯定的是，一旦克努特成为国王，戈德温的崛起速度就惊人地快。所以在1020年，克努特——在此之前他自己一直担任韦塞克斯伯爵，你知道的，他有一个庞大的帝国要统治，所以他其实不想挑起这个重担——于是他把这个职位交给了戈德温，戈德温成为了韦塞克斯伯爵。此外，
he marries him to his own sister-in-law, a Danish woman called Githa. And in consequence of that, you called Harold the last true born King of England, but I mean, he is half Danish, as is Tostig, as is Edith. So we think of them as the embodiments of Anglo-Saxon England, I guess, because they're ruling and living in the twilight of Anglo-Saxon England. But they are also evidence of the way in which England is an inextricable part of the Danish world as well. So in that sense, I guess they are really good embodiments of Anglo-Saxon England because of course for centuries Anglo-Saxon England has had a huge Danish component to it, hence
他还将自己的小姨子、一个名叫吉塔的丹麦女子嫁给了他。正因如此，你把哈罗德称为英格兰最后一个纯血国王，但我的意思是，他是有一半丹麦血统的，托斯蒂格也是，伊迪丝也是。所以我们认为他们是盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰的化身，我想，是因为他们统治并生活在盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰的黄昏时期。但他们也证明了英格兰与丹麦世界有着密不可分的联系。所以从这个意义上说，我想他们确实是盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰非常好的化身，因为当然几个世纪以来，盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰一直有着巨大的丹麦成分，因此
the place names and the people's personal names and the Thor's hammers and all of those kinds of things. So just on Godwin, you could say about Godwin, yes, he's a symbol of upward mobility. He's also a symbol of collaboration with an occupier. Yes. And it works for him because by the time Canute dies in 1035, he is indisputably the most powerful magnate in the kingdom. I mean, he is a figure whose support is key for anyone who wants to rule as king. And it is evidence of, you know, these powers of resourcefulness, of prudence, of opportunism, of charm that the life of King Edward alludes to and you know, this is essentially his own daughter praising him. But clearly the proof of these qualities is the fact that he's able to survive the shipwreck of Athelred's fortunes, profit
才有那些地名、人们的个人名字、雷神之锤以及所有这类东西。所以单就戈德温而言，你可以这样评价他：是的，他是向上流动的象征。他也是与占领者合作的象征。是的。这对他也确实管用，因为到1035年克努特去世时，他无疑是王国中最强大的权贵。我的意思是，他是一个任何想作为国王统治的人都必须争取其支持的关键人物。这证明了他足智多谋、审慎、机会主义和迷人的特质，《国王爱德华传》也暗示了这一点——你知道的，这本质上是他自己的女儿在赞美他。但显然，这些品质的证明在于，他能够在埃塞尔雷德家族财富倾覆的沉船中幸存下来，从中获利，
from them and then survive this kind of seesaw chain of succession with Canute, his two sons, and then Edward. So Godwin shows an unbelievable talent for swimming with the tide. So first of all, he backs Emma and Arthur Canute in the wake of Canute's death. Then when it's clear that Harold Harefoot is going to be king, he switches sides. When Alfred, Emma's son by athelred lands and people who listened to our previous episode will remember that Alfred gets seized along with his retinue. They all get kind of scalped, blinded, chained up, whatever, and Alfred himself is blinded and dies of his wounds. The guy who is responsible for this is Godwin.
然后又在克努特、他的两个儿子以及后来的爱德华这般如跷跷板般的连串权力更迭中生存下来。因此，戈德温表现出了令人难以置信的顺应时势的天赋。所以首先，在克努特死后，他支持埃玛和哈索克努特。然后，当赤足哈罗德显然要成为国王时，他叛变了。当埃玛和埃塞尔雷德的儿子阿尔弗雷德登陆时——听过我们上一集节目的听众会记得，阿尔弗雷德和他的随从被抓了。他们都被剥头皮、弄瞎、锁起来，诸如此类，而阿尔弗雷德本人也被弄瞎并因伤势过重而死。对此负有责任的家伙就是戈德温。
It is Godwin who supervises essentially the kind of the slaughter of Alfred and his retinue and supervises the guy who is the brother of Edward who is going to become king, his blinding in Ely. And then when Harthacnut becomes king, Godwin very smoothly moves back to serving him. But his most startling switchback is still to come because it is Godwin who plays the leading role in finessing the restoration of the original West Saxon ruling line to the English throne in the form of Edward the Confessor. And just to reiterate, it's startling partly because Godwin has inherited this grudge from his father against Ethelred. Yeah.
正是戈德温监督了阿尔弗雷德及其随从的大屠杀，并监督了即将成为国王的爱德华的兄弟在伊利的盲刑。然后，当哈索克努特成为国王时，戈德温非常顺利地回去伺候他。但他最惊人的大反转还在后面，因为正是戈德温在促成最初的西撒克逊统治血脉以忏悔者爱德华的形式重返英格兰王位中扮演了主导角色。再重申一遍，这之所以令人震惊，部分原因在于戈德温继承了他父亲对埃塞尔雷德的怨恨。是的。
More obviously, because his entire status as the most powerful magnate in England entirely derives from Danish rule and from the fact that Ethelred's family have been expelled. And above all, I guess, because he's the guy who blinded and essentially killed Edward's brother. But maybe there's an explanation for this, which is that Edward, as we will discuss, has been in Normandy for the great majority of his adult life. So he doesn't have the affinity, the connections, the networks in England. Whereas Godwin, he may hate Godwin and he may think, you know, I think it's completely reasonable that you might have a grudge against somebody who bribed and mutilated your brother.
更明显的原因是，他作为英格兰最有权势的权贵的全部地位完全源于丹麦人的统治，以及埃塞尔雷德家族被驱逐的事实。最重要的是，我想，因为他就是那个弄瞎并实质上杀死爱德华兄弟的人。但也许对此有一个解释，那就是正如我们所讨论的，爱德华成年后的绝大部分时间都在诺曼底度过。所以他在英格兰没有亲信、人脉和社交网络。而戈德温——尽管爱德华可能恨戈德温，并且可能会觉得，你知道的，你对一个曾经贿赂和残害你兄弟的人怀恨在心是完全合理的。
But Godwin does have all the patronage networks, all the connections, and it's presumably hard to do without him. Yeah. So it requires both of them to play politics. You know, it's a bit like, I suppose, Stammer bending the knee to Trump. Even though he obviously hates him. You know, sometimes you have to do stuff to get on in geopolitics. And this is kind of what's happening because they both have every reason for
但戈德温确实拥有所有的人脉网络、所有的关系，没有他恐怕很难办成事。是的。所以这需要双方都在政治上做出妥协。你知道，这有点像，我猜，斯塔默向特朗普屈膝。尽管他显然恨特朗普。你知道，有时为了在地缘政治中混下去，你不得不做一些事。这正是正在发生的事情，因为他们双方都有充分的理由
arriving at an accommodation because both depend on the other. So when Edward becomes king, Godwin is highly respectful. He gives him an absolutely magnificent warship, which is all ornamented with gold and has a kind of crew of 80 warriors who are wearing gilded armor. And in turn, Edward confirms Godwin in his rank as Earl of Wessex, which of course is what Godwin wants. And more than that, he promotes Godwin's sons. So Harold, for instance, even though he's only just 20 by this point, he becomes the Earl of East
达成妥协，因为彼此依赖。所以当爱德华成为国王时，戈德温表现得极其恭敬。他送给爱德华一艘绝对华丽的战舰，上面装饰着黄金，并配备了一支由80名身穿镀金盔甲的勇士组成的船员队伍。作为回报，爱德华确认了戈德温韦塞克斯伯爵的地位，这当然正是戈德温想要的。不仅如此，他还提拔了戈德温的儿子们。比如哈罗德，尽管此时他刚满20岁，却成为了东盎格拉
Anglia, which is a hugely powerful position. And it means that Godwin and his sons are ruling a large swathe of England, albeit under the headship of Edward. But there's a sense in which that's quite a nominal headship because as you pointed out, Edward doesn't really have the contacts and the affinities that a king who had grown up in England would automatically have had. He seems almost like a foreigner, I think. But obviously the biggest symbol of this is who Edward marries because when he arrives, he needs a wife and January 1043, he gets married and three months later his wife is crowned queen and the identity of this woman is Godwin's daughter Edith. I mean you could
伯爵，这是一个权势熏天的职位。这意味着戈德温和他的儿子们统治着英格兰大片土地，尽管名义上受爱德华的领导。但某种程度上，这种领导只是名义上的，正如你所指出的，爱德华并不具备在英格兰长大的国王所自然拥有的那些人脉和亲信。我觉得他看起来几乎像个外国人。但显而易见，这最大的象征就是爱德华娶了谁，因为当他抵达时，他需要一个妻子，于是在1043年1月，他结婚了，三个月后他的妻子加冕为王后，而这个女人的身份正是戈德温的女儿伊迪丝。我的意思是，你
hardly have a more powerful you know physical visual symbol of the reconciliation of the two men. Right and for Godwin it means that should Edith bear Edward's sons then there's every chance that his grandson will be King of England. So I mean, it's an incredible prize. Now, Edith herself is a very, very impressive woman. So I'm delighted to say that she was educated at Wilton, the great nunnery there. So she's not being, you know, she's not being ready to be a nun. It's more like a kind of very expensive boarding school. She's very learned in music, in mathematics, in astronomy. She's supposed to have spoken five languages, so her native English, Danish it got from her mother, Latin, French and brilliantly Irish. She's very skilled at
几乎找不出比这更有力量的、肉眼可见的象征，来代表这两个男人的和解了。没错，对于戈德温来说，这意味着如果伊迪丝能为爱德华生下儿子，那么他的外孙将极有可能是英格兰国王。所以我的意思是，这是一个难以置信的巨大奖赏。现在，伊迪丝本人是一个非常、非常出色的女性。所以我很高兴地说，她曾在威尔顿受过教育，那是那里的一座伟大修女院。所以她不是在接受，你知道的，她不是在准备当修女。这更像是一种非常昂贵的寄宿学校。她在音乐、数学、天文学方面都很有学问。据说她会说五种语言，即她的母语英语、从母亲那里学来的丹麦语、拉丁语、法语，还有极其精通的爱尔兰语。她非常擅长
embroidery and she is described admittedly by this Life of King Edward that she herself has sponsored as being ineffably beautiful. I'm sure she was. So anyway, I was kind of reading the life of King Edward when we got our little kittens that would grow up to become Tostig and Edith. And I called our girl cat Edith because I was reading about this.
刺绣，而且据承认——虽然是由她自己资助的这本《国王爱德华传》所描述——她拥有无可言喻的美貌。我相信她是这样的。不管怎样，当我们得到那两只后来长成托斯蒂格和伊迪丝的小猫时，我正在读《国王爱德华传》。我把我们的母猫叫作伊迪丝，因为我当时正在读这方面的书。
So she's ineffably beautiful. And there's this wonderful description of her. Edith gem-like on the kingdom's breast, all virtues friend. So that's how I like to think of my cat. But no Harold, Tom. That's poor. So we did have a Harold as well, but he ran away. Oh, cranky. Really sad.
所以她拥有无可言喻的美貌。书中对她有一段极美的描述：伊迪丝如宝石般镶嵌在王国的胸膛上，是一切美德的朋友。这就是我喜欢想象我的猫的方式。但没有哈罗德，汤姆。这太逊了。我们其实也有一个叫哈罗德的，但他跑掉了。哦，天哪。真让人难过。
So he got lost. Right. We just have Tostig and Edith. Okay. I think that it does Edith, my cat, great credit to have been named after this remarkable queen. She's very, very formidable. And on Royal charters, the moment that she has been crowned, she is appearing kind of second to
所以它走失了。没错。我们只有托斯蒂格和伊迪丝了。好吧。我觉得我的猫伊迪丝以这位非凡的王后来命名，实在是它的莫大荣誉。她非常、非常令人敬畏。在王室宪章上，她一经加冕，其署名就排在
Edward himself. And I guess for the people of England, her presence beside Edward on his throne is a kind of moving symbol of this reconciliation between King and the great magnate who had put all England in his shadow, undertaken for the good of the English people and well befitting a Christian king with the care of his people uppermost in his mind. Right. But there is a cloud, right? There is one issue, which is there's one thing anybody who's ever heard of Henry VIII knows there is one thing a king has to do and Edward does not do it because they don't have any children.
爱德华本人之后。我想对于英格兰人民来说，她陪伴在爱德华王位旁的出现，是国王与那位曾将整个英格兰笼罩在其阴影之下的伟大权贵之间和解的动人象征，此举乃是为了英格兰人民的福祉，也极为符合一位将子民福祉放在首位的基督教国王的身份。没错。但这里有一片阴云，对吧？有一个问题，那就是正如任何听说过亨利八世的人都知道的，国王必须做一件事，而爱德华没有做到，因为他们没有任何孩子。
Right. And the years go by, so four, five, six years, and still Edith hasn't given Edward an heir. It's harsh to blame it on Edith, Tom. I mean... Well, it might be Edward's fault, it might be Edith's. The truth is that this is a marriage that has prompted enormous speculation. And I guess that there are probably two principal theories as to why Edith does not give Edward a son. And the first of these, which is first mentioned by an English historian writing at Malmesbury
没错。岁月流逝，四年、五年、六年过去，伊迪丝依然没有给爱德华生下继承人。把这归咎于伊迪丝未免太苛刻了，汤姆。我是说……好吧，可能是爱德华的问题，也可能是伊迪丝的问题。事实是，这是一桩引发了巨大猜测的婚姻。我想，关于伊迪丝为什么没有给爱德华生下一个儿子，大概有两个主要的理论。其中第一个理论，最早由一位名叫威廉的马姆斯伯里英文历史学家提出，即马姆斯伯里的威廉。我的意思是，他非常像你在童书模式下的样子。他热爱这个故事，而且，你知道，如果有某种有趣的视角可以采用，他绝对会采用。谢谢你，汤姆。你真好。而且他非常爱国。所以有点像，是的，12世纪的多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。所以马姆斯伯里的威廉的理论是，
called William, William of Malmesbury. I mean, he's very much, I think, like you in your children's book mode. He loves the story and, you know, if there's a kind of entertaining perspective to adopt, he will absolutely adopt it. Thanks, Tom. That's kind. And he's very patriotic. So the kind of, yeah, the Dominic Sandbrook of the 12th century. So William of Malmesbury's theory is that that Edward is consumed with such hatred and resentment of Godwin that he can't bear to sleep with Godwin's daughter. That Edith may be ineffably beautiful and brilliant at speaking Irish and embroidery
爱德华对戈德温怀有如此深的仇恨和怨恨，以至于他无法忍受和戈德温的女儿同床共枕。伊迪丝可能有着无可言喻的美貌，精通爱尔兰语和刺绣
and stuff, but he doesn't care. He doesn't want to have anything to do with her. Can't bear to be touched by her. Don't believe it. I just don't believe that story. I think if she's that beautiful, you'd overlook your animus against the father. In fact, the animus against the father might be an incentive. Well possible support for this theory has been adduced in the life of King Edward, where
等等，但他根本不在乎。他不想和她有任何瓜葛。根本无法忍受被她触碰。我不信。我就是不相信这个故事。我觉得如果她长得那么漂亮，你会忽略你对她父亲的敌意。事实上，对父亲的敌意甚至可能成为一种刺激。好吧，对这个理论的可能支持可以在《国王爱德华传》中找到，其中
it says that Edward has consecrated himself to chastity. Okay. So maybe that's Edith's way of saying, well, you know, there were slight problems, but I think there's another reason for that that will come to in due course. And I would also just throw in here the opinion of Pauline Stafford, who is the great expert on 11th century English queens. And she says, it is futile to speculate on the sex lives, sex drives or sexuality of 11th century kings from such sparse and partial evidence.
写道，爱德华已经将自己奉献给纯洁。好吧。所以也许那是伊迪丝的一种委婉说法，你知道的，确实存在一些小问题，但我认为这背后还有另一个原因，我们随后会讲到。我在这里也想顺便提出保利娜·斯塔福德的观点，她是研究11世纪英国王后的伟大专家。她说，根据如此稀少和片面的证据去猜测11世纪国王的性生活、性冲动或性取向是徒劳的。
Tom, if we are, if we adopted that attitude, I mean, our podcast will be about 20 minutes shorter by and large. I'm not sure that's true. evidence. Tom, if we adopted that attitude, I mean, our podcasts would be about 20 minutes shorter, by and large. I'm not sure that's true. I think we've repeatedly said that we can't impose kind of 21st century standards of sexual psychology. We have. We try not to.
汤姆，如果我们是的话，如果我们采取那种态度，我的意思是，我们的播客总体上要短大约20分钟。我不确定这是不是真的。证据。汤姆，如果我们采取那种态度，我的意思是，我们的播客总体上要短大约20分钟。我不确定这是不是真的。我想我们已经多次说过，我们不能把21世纪的性心理学标准强加进去。我们说过。我们尽量不这么做。
We normally say that after we've spent the previous eight minutes. I agree. I agree. Entertainingly speculating. Which is what we've just done. Yeah, exactly. But I don't think that that is the key to it. So the other possibility, of course, is that Edith or Edward can't have children.
我们通常在我们花了前八分钟之后才这么说。我同意。我同意。进行有趣的猜测。而这正是我们刚才所做的。是的，完全正确。但我认为这并非关键所在。所以另一种可能性，当然，是伊迪丝或爱德华无法生育。
That seems to me a much more plausible explanation. I mean, Edward would want to father children. He would want to propagate his line. And I think the evidence for this is that by the end of 1050, so that's five years after his marriage to Edith, it's clear that he is maneuvering to divorce her and by implication remarry. Right. And I think the consequence of this is the first great crisis in English history precipitated
在我看来，这似乎是一个合理得多的解释。我的意思是，爱德华会想要生养子女。他会想要延续自己的血脉。我认为这方面的证据是，到1050年底——也就是他与伊迪丝结婚五年后——很明显他正在策划与她离婚，潜台词是准备再婚。没错。我认为这带来的后果是英格兰历史上第一场由国王想要新妻子的愿望所引发的重大危机。所以你提到了亨利八世。这就是这种趋势开始的地方。所以顺着这个思路，对亨利八世来说问题在于。这是，你知道的，这就是这种趋势开始的地方。所以顺着这个思路，对亨利八世来说，问题当然在于他将自己对立于西班牙国王、教皇等等。而对爱德华来说，问题在于他将自己对立于，从短期来看，是一个更危险的对手，因为那当然就是戈德温，王国中最有权势的人。好吧，他并不——他确实有盟友，不是吗？我的意思是，这是我们应该说的一点，因为还有其他不喜欢戈德温的权贵，王国中最有权势的人。所以好吧，他并不——他确实有盟友，不是吗？
by a king's desire to get a new wife. So you alluded to Henry VIII. This is where that trend all kicks off. So to pursue that thread, the issue for Henry VIII. This is, you know, this is where that trend all kicks off. So to pursue that thread, the issue for Henry VIII, of course, was that he was setting himself against the King of Spain, the Pope and so on and so forth. The issue for Edward is that he is setting himself against in the short term, a more dangerous opponent, because that of course is Godwin, the most powerful person in the kingdom. So, well, he doesn't he does have allies, doesn't he? I mean, that's one thing we should say, because there are other magnates who don't like Godwin, the most powerful person in the kingdom. So well, he doesn't he does have allies, doesn't he?
我的意思是，这是我们应该说的一点，因为还有其他不喜欢戈德温的权贵。是的。所以特别有两个。一个是诺森布里亚伯爵，此时是一位名叫西华德的丹麦人。读过或看过《麦克白》的人可能还记得他在其中出场。历史上，西华德曾两度对麦克白发动对苏格兰的入侵，爱德华非常信任他。另一个人叫勒夫里克，他是麦西亚伯爵，他同样是那种从丹麦入侵中获利的英国贵族之一。
I mean, that's one thing we should say, because there are other magnates who don't like Godwin. Yeah. So there are two in particular. There's the Earl of Northumberland, which by this point is a Dane called Seward. And people who've read or watched Macbeth may remember that he features in that. Historically, Seward launches two invasions of Scotland against Macbeth and Edward really trusts him. The other is a guy called Leifric and he is the Earl of Mercia and he again is one of the kind of English nobles who has profited from the Danish invasion.
阿尔吉弗（Alf Giffo）——克努特的第一任妻子、赤足哈罗德的母亲——可能与他有亲戚关系。嗯，这就说得通了，因为他在继承危机中支持过赤足哈罗德，不是吗？是的。这就是为什么勒夫里克能成为麦西亚伯爵的原因。他在英国民间传说中最著名的身份可能是一个名叫戈吉弗（Gogiffo）的女性的丈夫，这个名字后来演变成了戈黛娃（Godiva），也就是骑马裸行穿过考文垂街道的戈黛娃夫人。是的，考文垂发生过的最好的事情。
It's possible that Alf Giffo, who is Canute's first wife, the mother of Harold Harefoot, that she may been related to him. Will that would make sense because he'd backed Harefoot, hadn't he, in the succession crisis? Yes. So this is why Leofric is where he is as Earl of Mercia. And he is probably best known in English folklore as the husband of a woman called Gogiffo, which comes to be Godiva, as in Lady Godiva, who rides naked through the streets of Coventry. Yeah, best thing that's ever happened in Coventry.
这很有趣，因为勒夫里克在那个传说中被塑造成一个征收过多税款的人，这再次提醒人们，在11世纪，英国人是西欧赋税最重的群体。所以这一切都关乎伯爵们从人民身上榨取金钱的能力。那么诺曼人呢？因为爱德华当然在诺曼底度过了多年，他来的时候也带了一些诺曼人，不是吗？他确实带了。是的，他带了。我们昨天谈到在法国正在酝酿一场军事革命，
And it's interesting because Leofric in that is cast as a man who is exacting too many taxes, and it's a reminder again of the fact that in the 11th century, the English are the most heavily taxed people in Western Europe. So it's all about the ability of earls to extract money from people. And then what about the Normans? Because Edward, of course, has spent so many years in Normandy and he brings some Normans with him when he comes, doesn't he? He does. Yes, he does. And we talked yesterday about how in France there is this brewing military revolution
其最突出的象征就是城堡。实际上，确实有一些诺曼人在英格兰被授予土地并建造了城堡。其中一人是爱德华的连襟，名叫拉ルフ（Ralph），他拥有“胆小鬼”这一辉煌的称号，我想如果我是诺曼领主，这大概就是我的称号了。他成为了赫里福德郡伯爵并在那里建了一座城堡。还有一个来自于瑞日（Jumierges）地方的修道院长，名叫罗伯特，他被爱德华任命为伦敦主教，然后又在1051年被任命为坎特伯雷大主教。所以在某种程度上，诺曼人——我的意思是人们总是说如果诺曼征服从未发生会怎样，但英格兰世界与诺曼世界的融合早在1066年很久之前就已经开始了。
of which the most prominent symbol is the castle. And actually, there are Normans who are given lands in England and who build castles. So one of them is a brother-in-law of Edward, he's called Ralph and he has the brilliant suprachae of the timid, which I think is what I would have if I was a Norman Lord. And he becomes the Earl of Herefordshire and he builds a castle there. There is also an Abbot from a place called Jumierges, he's called Robert and he is appointed by Edward Bishop of London and then in 1051 Archbishop of Canterbury. So to some degree the Norman, I mean people always say what if the Norman conquest never
嗯，这可以追溯到埃玛嫁给埃塞尔雷德，我的意思是这是一个长期的过程，但戈德温当然不喜欢它。特别是任命于瑞日的罗伯特为坎特伯雷大主教，他对此气急败坏，因为他本希望由他自己安插的人选来得到这份工作。这加速了爱德华和戈德温之间关系的迅速崩塌。我认为关系崩塌的速度反映了这样一个事实：爱德华现在开始
happened, but the integration of the English and the Norman worlds has already started long before 1066. Well it goes all the way back to Emma marrying Ethelred, I mean it's been an ongoing process but Godwin certainly doesn't like it. And particularly the appointment of Robert of Jumier as Archbishop of Canterbury, he's furious about this because he'd wanted one of his own placements to get the job. And it precipitates a rapid meltdown in relations between Edward and Godwin. And I think the pace of the meltdown is reflective of the fact that Edward is starting
设法摆脱伊迪丝，因为他想要孩子。但新任坎特伯雷大主教公开且一再地冷落戈德温，这显然对缓和局势毫无帮助；而且许多来到伦敦的诺曼人——或者可能正返回诺曼底等地的诺曼人——对戈德温极其不敬，几乎就像他们是在国王的暗示下才这么做的一样。当然我们并不知道，这可能是一个过于阴谋论的猜测，但在1051年8月发生过一个臭名昭著的事件：在多佛发生了一场大规模的混战，当时一名诺曼贵族及其随从据称遭到袭击，爱德华对此大发雷霆，他命令戈德温前去惩罚性地洗劫多佛。没错。
to angle now to try and get rid of Edith because he wants children. But it's certainly not helped by the new Archbishop of Canterbury who is openly and repeatedly snubbing Godwin and also lots of the Normans who have come over to London or you know maybe heading back to Normandy or whatever are disrespecting Godwin quite seriously, almost as though they're being prompted to perhaps by the king. I mean, we don't know that might be a conspiracy too far, but there's a notorious occasion in August 1051 where there's a massive fracas in Dover when a Norman nobleman in his retinue are supposedly attacked and Edward is furious about this and he orders Godwin to go and ravaged over
你知道，这是英国传统司法形式。我们谈到过埃德加总是四处洗劫那些惹恼他的地方。是的。因此他的绰号是“和平者”。正是如此。而戈德温拒绝了。
as a punishment. Right. You know, this is a traditional form of English justice. We talked about how Edgar was always ravaging places that annoyed him. Yeah. Hence his nickname, the peaceable. Exactly. And Godwin refuses.
这些人是他的子民。他基本上是英格兰南部的伯爵。他不想做这种事。他被置于一个极其尴尬的境地，人们不禁认为这是爱德华刻意做出的策略，旨在将戈德温逼入死角。这带来的后果是，到1051年9月，戈德温和他的儿子们开始召集他们的征召兵。他们正在为战争做准备，而爱德华则传召了诺森布里亚和麦西亚的伯爵西华德和勒夫里克，要求他们召集征召兵前来保卫他。
These are his people. He is the Earl of essentially of southern England. He doesn't want to have to do that. He's put in a completely invidious position and you can't help thinking that it's a deliberate maneuver on the part of Edwards to force Godwin into a corner. And the consequence of this is that by September 1051, Godwin and his sons are starting to raise their levies. They're preparing for war and Edward then summons Seward and Leofric, the earls of Northumberland and Mercia, to raise their levies and come to his defence.
这两支庞大的军队对峙了。你知道的，他们列阵相向，但随后他们犹豫了。盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史解释了其中的原因：有些人认为如果他们加入战斗将是极大的愚蠢。当时英格兰几乎所有的贵族都在那两支队伍中，他们确信，如果开战，他们就会让国家门户大开，任由敌人入侵，并给自己带来彻底的毁灭。
And these two great armies confront each other. You know, they're lined up, but then they hesitate. And the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle explains why. Some of them considered that it would be great folly if they joined battle. Almost all the noblest in England were present in those two companies, and they were convinced that they would be leaving the country open to the invasion of our enemies and be bringing utter ruin upon themselves. Isn't that interesting that they're already anticipating the possibility that, you know,
这难道不有趣吗？他们当时就已经在预测这种可能性了，你知道的，
neighbouring predators might make a move? But I mean, think about it. These are all people who've lived through the Danish conquest. I mean, I'm sure they're thinking of the Vikings rather than the Normans, but I mean, you know, they know that a house divided is, I mean, it's not a good place to be. So negotiations are opened and it's agreed that Godwin will come to London in a fortnight's time after this meeting and he will be put in trial and Godwin agrees and he's planning to go to London with his army. But his levees start to melt away and even before the two weeks are up, he realizes that he's finished. And so he takes horse, takes ship, heads off to Flanders and his wife and
邻近的掠夺者可能会采取行动。但我的意思是，想想看，这些人都是经历过丹麦征服的人。我的意思是，我确信他们想到的是维京人而不是诺曼人，但我的意思是，你知道，他们知道一个分裂之家——我的意思是，这不是一个好去处。于是谈判开始了，双方商定戈德温将在这次会面两周后来到伦敦接受审判，戈德温表示同意，并计划带着他的军队前往伦敦。但他的征召兵开始流失，甚至在两周期限到期之前，他就意识到自己完蛋了。于是他骑上马，登上船，前往弗兰德斯，他的妻子和
sons also flee. So Harold flees to Ireland. The only significant figure of the Godwin family who is left is Edith, Edward's queen, and she is immediately packed off to a nunnery. Edith will say that it was Wilton and will imply that it was a kind of a rather pleasant retirement, but probably she is sent off to another nunnery which effectively serves as a prison. So shades of the, you know, the Merovingians, which we talked about in the Franks. Right. So here we are at the end of 1051. The Godwins, it looks like they're out, they're down.
儿子们也纷纷逃亡。因此哈罗德逃到了爱尔兰。戈德温家族中唯一留下的重要人物是爱德华的王后伊迪丝，她立刻被打包送进了一座修女院。伊迪丝会说那是威尔顿，并暗示那是一种相当惬意的退休生活，但很可能她被送到了另一座实际上充当监狱的修女院。所以这有点像墨洛温王朝的影子，我们之前在法兰克人那一集里谈到过。没错。所以这就是1051年底的情况。戈德温家族，看起来他们出局了，失势了。
But I guess the issue for Edward now is that by kicking out the Godwins, he has thrown his lot in completely with Seward and Leofric and he's in their power to some extent, isn't he? I mean, basically because he's, there is now no counterbalance to them. Yes. And so it's not surprising that they are confirmed in more grants of land. Harold has been the Earl of East Anglia. There's now a vacancy.
但我想爱德华现在面临的问题是，通过赶走戈德温，他已经把宝完全押在了西华德和勒夫里克身上，并在某种程度上受制于他们，不是吗？我的意思是，基本上是因为现在没有能够制衡他们的力量了。是的。因此他们确认获得更多土地的赏赐也就不足为奇了。哈罗德曾是东盎格拉伯爵。现在那个职位空缺了。
So Leofric's son, Alfgar, he gets that job. So clearly, you know, jobs for the boys. I mean, that's part of the deal. But Edward does have other allies beyond England because of course he has all these contacts in Normandy. And it is now in the wake of Godwin's flight that the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle reports a key development. And it's a sentence that has been so discussed and I'll read it. Then came Duke William from beyond the sea with a great retinue of Frenchmen, and the king received him and as many of his companions
所以勒夫里克的儿子阿尔夫加得到了那份工作。很显然，你知道的，肥水不流外人田。我的意思是，这是交易的一部分。但爱德华在英格兰之外确实还有其他盟友，因为他当然在诺曼底有着所有这些人脉。正是在戈德温逃亡之后，盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史记录了一个关键进展。有这样一句话，引起了如此多的讨论，我把它读出来：接着，威廉公爵带着一大批法兰克人随从从海外归来，国王接待了他以及随行的
as it pleased him. What does receive mean? I think it means slightly more than just, oh, come in and have a drink. It's more kind of, William is almost becoming his vassal. He's offering him kind of pledges of support in a way that affirms Edward's rank as king. But the question then is, well, what has Edward
众多同伴，任凭他心意如何。这里的“接待”是什么意思？我想它所代表的意义略微超出了一般的“噢，进来喝一杯吧”。这更像是威廉几乎正在成为他的附庸。他以一种肯定爱德华国王身份的方式向他宣誓效力。但随之而来的问题是，爱德华究竟给了威廉什么
given William in return? The Anglo-Saxon Chronicle doesn't say, no English source says, but Norman sources insist that what Edward has done is to promise William the crown should Edward not have sons. So in the words of David Douglas, who's the author of the definitive recent biography of William, there can be no reasonable doubt that before the end of 1051, he had nominated William of Normandy as his heir. But some historians do doubt it though, don't they? I mean, some historians are like, well, we cannot be certain what the arrangement was and it may have been much less, you know, he may have made noises, but not
作为回报？盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史没有说，没有任何英国消息来源提及，但诺曼消息来源坚称，爱德华所做的是向威廉承诺，如果爱德华没有儿子，就把王位传给他。用威廉近期权威传记作者大卫·道格拉斯的话来说，毫无合理疑问的是，在1051年底之前，他已经指定诺曼底的威廉为他的继承人。但一些历史学家对此表示怀疑，不是吗？我的意思是，一些历史学家觉得，好吧，我们无法确定当时的具体安排是什么，他可能表达得没那么确定，你知道的，他可能释放过一些信号，但并非板上钉钉。我的意思是，既然史料中如此含糊其辞……好吧，我认为，爱德华在没有子嗣的期间，一直将“他可以指定某人为继承人”这种可能性作为一种谈判筹码，对吧？从某种意义上说，这几乎是他手中能打出的最强底牌。
being definitive. I mean, the fact that it's so vague in the sources. Well, I think that, that Edward, for as long as he is childless uses the possibility that he could nominate someone as long as he is childless uses the possibility that he could nominate someone as king as a kind of bargaining chip, right? In a way, it's it's almost the strongest card he has to play. Yeah, I'm fairly sure he does suggest this to William. But of course, one of the reasons why he does it is that he is kind of.
是的，我相当确信他确实向威廉暗示过这一点。但当然，他这么做的一个原因是他正在……
You know, he's looking to get a new wife. He's looking to have a son. And if he has a son, then, you know, no problem. William won't become king. But the problem is, of course, that, you know, he doesn't yet have a wife or a son in place. And you could imagine that if Edward had, you know, had not had a son, and if this agreement on Edward's part that William became king in his succession had gone through, you could imagine quite a kind of, you know, a peaceable process of And if this agreement on Edward's part that William became king in his succession had gone through, you could imagine quite a kind of, you know, a peaceable process of succession that William might well have become king.
你知道的，他在寻找新妻子，在寻找生个儿子。如果他有了儿子，那么，你知道的，就没问题了，威廉就不会成为国王。但问题当然在于，你知道，他当时还没有妻子或儿子到位。你可以想象，如果爱德华——你知道——没有儿子，并且如果爱德华关于由威廉继承王位的这项协议得以实行的话，你可以想象一个相当……你知道的，一个和平的王位继承过程，威廉很可能会成为国王。
And it would have, the whole process would have been a lot less brutal. But the thing is that all of this is dependent on Godwin and his family remaining safely in exile. And I guess that if there is a theme of this series, it's the fact that people who are driven into exile always come back. They always come back. Well, they, I mean, all of the people, almost all the people we talk about spend time in exile, don't they? And make astonishing comebacks. Astonishing comebacks. And this is what happens in August 1052. So the year after Godwin's
而且整个过程会残酷得多。但问题是，这一切都取决于戈德温和他的家人能否安然呆在流放地。我想，如果这个系列有一个主题的话，那就是被驱逐流放的人总是会回来。他们总是会回来。好吧，他们——我的意思是，所有人，几乎所有我们讨论过的人都经历过流放，不是吗？并且实现了惊人的卷土重来。惊人的卷土重来。而这正是1052年8月发生的事情。就在戈德温逃亡的一年之后，
flight, Godwin has not been twiddling his thumbs. He has been recruiting an enormous fleet. He's been raising an army and in the summer of 1052, he sails from Flanders with his fleet. Harold, meanwhile, has been raising a fleet in Ireland. The two of them meet on the south coast of England and they start kind of ravaging the south coast. And Edward is thrown into a panic. He doesn't have the levees to hand or indeed the fleet because he's actually cut back on the taxes that would have kept the fleet going. Very, very foolish move. And so he's a bit stuck. And 14th of September, the Godwins sail up the Thames in triumph and they dock at the south end of London Bridge,
戈德温可没有闲着。他一直在组建一支庞大的舰队，一直在招兵买马，并在1052年夏天，他率领舰队从弗兰德斯起航。与此同时，哈罗德一直在爱尔兰组建舰队。两人在英格兰南部海岸会合，并开始四处洗劫南部海岸。爱德华陷入了恐慌。他手头没有现成的征召兵，也没有舰队，因为他实际上削减了原本用于维持舰队运转的税收。这是一个非常、非常愚蠢的举动。因此他有点进退维谷。9月14日，戈德温家族乘船顺泰晤士河凯旋而上，并在伦敦桥南端停靠，
so in Southwark. London is held against them, it's got the great Roman walls and Edward thinks, well, I can defy them. But the mass of people, not just in London, but across England, they say it's not worth fighting over. And also, there's quite a lot of resentment of the rumours that Edward has nominated William of Normandy, his heir. People don't like the Normans. They think, ah, we'd rather have Godwin than a load of foreigners. And so Edward ultimately finds himself with no choice but to welcome the Godwins back. And Godwin plays it very cool. He doesn't humiliate the king. He kneels before
也就是在萨瑟克。伦敦城据守抵抗他们，这里有着高大的罗马城墙，爱德华觉得，好吧，我可以抗衡他们。但广大民众，不仅在伦敦，而且在全英格兰，都认为这不值得为之大打出手。而且，对于爱德华已经提名诺曼底的威廉为继承人的传言，也有相当多的怨言。人们不喜欢诺曼人。他们想，啊，我们宁愿要戈德温，也不要一帮外国人。因此，爱德华最终发现自己别无选择，只能欢迎戈德温归来。而戈德温表现得非常冷静。他没有羞辱国王。他在国王面前双膝跪地。
him. He begs his royal forgiveness, he insists that he'd been misrepresented and is innocent of all the charges against him. And Edward has no choice but to accept this. And both Godwin and Harold are restored to their respective earldoms. And Edith returns in triumph from her exile and imprisonment in her nunnery, back to her husband's side. There she is, an anointed queen by the side of her husband, the anointed king. And clearly this means that there is now no more talk of divorce, which in turn probably means that there is no more prospect of Edward having an heir. And the life of King Edward, I mean, it celebrates this in
他请求国王的宽恕，坚称自己被诬陷，对针对他的一切指控是无辜的。爱德华别无选择，只能接受这一点。戈德温和哈罗德都恢复了各自的伯爵身份。埃迪特从流放和修道院的监禁中凯旋归来，回到了丈夫身边。她就坐在那里，一个受膏的王后，陪伴着受膏的国王丈夫。显然，这意味着现在不再有关于离婚的讨论，这反过来可能意味着爱德华不再有继承人的希望。爱德华国王的一生，我的意思是，它以
delighted tones. The whole country settled down in peaceful tranquility. But of course, the question is, will this peaceful tranquility hold? And I guess you could say that the legacy of the Godwins exile and return is threefold. So firstly, the Godwins are now absolutely secure as the greatest dynasty in England. Edith, as we said, is now secure as Queen, so no real prospect of them having children now. And of course, there are these reports, a consequence of the Godwins' exile, that Edward has promised William the throne.
喜悦的语气歌颂了这一点。全国上下陷入了和平与安宁。但是，问题当然是，这种和平与安宁能维持多久？我想你可以说，戈德温流放和归来的遗产体现在三个方面。首先，戈德温家族现在作为英格兰最伟大的王朝绝对稳固了。正如我们所说，埃迪特现在作为王后的地位很稳固，所以他们现在生孩子的希望渺茫。当然，由于戈德温的流放，有报道称爱德华曾向威廉承诺过王位。
So you can see that is quite a combustible blend of circumstances. Now there are 15 years to go. The clock is ticking towards the point at which these combustible circumstances will ignite and we will speed up that process after the break. Hello, I'm William Durrimple. And I'm Anita Arnand and we are the hosts of Empire, also from Goalhanger. And we're here to tell you about our recent mini-series that we've just done on The Troubles. In it, we try to get to the very heart of the violent conflict in Northern Ireland that lasted from the 1960s all the way up to 1998.
所以你可以看到，这是一组合情合理的易燃环境。现在还有15年时间。时钟滴答作响，指向这些易燃环境将被点燃的时刻，我们将在中场休息后加速这一进程。你好，我是威廉·达林普尔。我是阿尼塔·阿南德，我们是《帝国》的主持人，该节目同样来自Goalhanger。我们在这里向大家介绍我们刚刚制作的关于“北爱尔兰问题”的迷你剧。在剧中，我们试图深入探讨北爱尔兰从20世纪60年代一直持续到1998年的暴力冲突的核心。
It's something that we both lived through and remember from our childhoods, but younger listeners may not know anything about it. It's the time when there was division along religious and political lines, neighbours turned against each other, residential city streets became battlegrounds, thousands were killed and the IRA bombed London. It seemed as if an end was out of reach, but in 1998, a peace process finally brought those 30 years of violence to an end. But the memory of the troubles is still present, not only within Northern Irish communities who experienced it, but in international relations and political approaches to peace.
这是我们两人都经历过并从童年记忆中记得的事情，但年轻的听客可能对此一无所知。那是沿着宗教和政治阵营分裂的时期，邻居们反目成仇，住宅区街道变成战场，数千人丧生，爱尔兰共和军轰炸了伦敦。似乎和平遥不可及，但在1998年，和平进程终于结束了这30年的暴力。然而，北爱尔兰问题的记忆依然存在，不仅在经历过它的北爱尔兰社区内，而且在国际关系和政治和平方法中也是如此。
And new audiences are starting to understand this national trauma through films like Belfast and kneecap and TV shows like Derry Girls. In fact, our guest on the mini-series is Patrick Radden-Keefe. Now, he's the author of the non-fiction book that inspired the hit TV drama Say Nothing. It's one of my favorite books. It's, I think, the kind of inkhole blood for our generation, extraordinary work of non-fiction. And if you'd like to hear more about this very recent conflict that put Northern Ireland on the global stage and hear from Patrick Radden-Keefe, we've left a clip of the mini-series at the end of this episode. To hear the full series, just search Empire wherever you get your podcasts.
新的观众开始通过像《贝尔法斯特》和《膝盖》这样的电影以及像《德里女孩》这样的电视节目来理解这种国家创伤。事实上，我们迷你剧的嘉宾是帕特里克·拉登-基夫。现在，他是催生热门电视剧《无所知》的非虚构书籍的作者。这是我最喜欢的书之一。我认为它是我们这一代人的墨血之作，一部非凡的非虚构作品。如果您想了解更多关于这场将北爱尔兰推向全球舞台的近期冲突，并听听帕特里克·拉登-基夫的讲述，我们在本集结尾留下了迷你剧的一个片段。要收听完整系列，只需在您获取播客的任何地方搜索“Empire”。
Beyond the walls of London, beside the River Thames, there stood a monastery dedicated to St Peter. It was an insignificant place, and under its abbot only a small community of monks served Christ. The King, therefore, devoted as he was to God, fixed his attention on the spot, for not only was it close to a rich and famous city, but it was also a delightful spot, surrounded with fertile land and green fields and near the main channel of the river, which bore abundant merchandise of wares of every kind
在伦敦城墙之外，泰晤士河畔，曾有一座献给圣彼得的修道院。那是一个微不足道的地方，在其住持的领导下，只有一个小规模的修士社区在侍奉基督。因此，国王对上帝虔诚无比，将目光投向了这个地方，因为这里不仅靠近一个富裕而著名的城市，而且是一个风景宜人的地方，周围环绕着肥沃的土地和绿色的田野，靠近河流的主航道，河上载运着来自全世界的各种丰盛的商品货物，
for sale from the whole world to the town on its banks. So that's an account in the life of King Edward about how Edward the Confessor came to build a great abbey or a minster as the Anglo-Saxons called it to the west of London. So it's to the west of London and it's a minster and guess what they end up calling it? Westminster. Duh. Well, amazing. So Tom, this is the origin of Westminster Abbey. Yeah. And as you said, it comes from the life of King Edward, which remember is commissioned by Edith, his queen. And so her fingerprints are all over this account. And this life has two particular goals. And the first is to cast Edward as essentially a saintly figure,
出售给河岸边的城镇。因此，那是《爱德华国王生平》中关于忏悔者爱德华如何在伦敦以西建造一座伟大的修道院（盎格鲁-撒克逊人称之为minster）的记载。所以它在伦敦以西，是一座大教堂，你猜他们最后管它叫什么？威斯敏斯特。废话。嗯，太神奇了。所以，汤姆，这就是威斯敏斯特教堂的起源。是的。正如你所说，它源自《爱德华国王生平》，请记住，这是由他的王后埃迪特委托编写的。因此，她的指纹遍布这篇记载。这部传记有两个特殊的目标。首先是将爱德华塑造成一个本质上如圣人般的人物，
a confessor. And the second is to associate herself, Edith, with this saintliness. And this is why after this life has described how Edward sponsors the building of his great Abbey at Westminster, it then goes on to describe how Edith rebuilt Wilton, you know, where she'd been raised and this kind of great centre of West Saxon holiness to rebuild this Abbey in stone. And that is kind of essentially casting her as her husband's partner in godliness. And what the life does not do when it accounts Edward's building of Westminster Abbey is to point out that he's also building an enormous palace. So pretty much where the Houses of Parliament are now. So essentially it's an enormous royal complex, but she doesn't want that mentioned because it slightly detracts from the sense of him as a man utterly devoted to God.
一个忏悔者。第二个是将她自己（埃迪特）与这种圣洁联系起来。这就是为什么在这部传记描述了爱德华如何资助在威斯敏斯特建造他那宏伟的修道院之后，接着描述了埃迪特如何用石头重建威尔顿——你知道的，她长大的地方以及西撒克逊圣洁的这个伟大中心——来重建这座修道院。这基本上是将她塑造成她丈夫在虔诚之中的伴侣。当传记记录爱德华建造威斯敏斯特教堂时，它没有做的事情是指出他还在建造一座巨大的宫殿。基本上就在现在议会大厦所在的地方。所以本质上这是一个巨大的皇家综合体，但她不希望提及这一点，因为这稍微减损了他作为一个人完全献身于上帝的形象。
And likewise, it's this life which we said before, which insists that Edward willingly consecrates himself to virginity. And I think that we can see reasons for that that have nothing to do with Edward supposedly not allowing Edith into his bed, because essentially by saying that Edward has consecrated himself to chastity, it's failing the failure of Edith to give him a child, which is the prime responsibility of a queen. It doesn't matter how unfair that is. If you don't, you've essentially you failed as a queen.
同样地，正是这部传记——我们之前说过——坚称爱德华自愿将自己奉献给纯洁。我认为我们可以看到其中的原因，这与爱德华所谓的不允许埃迪特上他的床没有任何关系，因为本质上，通过说爱德华将自己奉献给贞洁，它掩盖了埃迪特未能给他生下一个孩子的失败，而这是王后的首要责任。无论这多么不公平，如果你做不到，你基本上作为王后就失败了。
And also it associates her with this kind of saintly project of chastity because by extension she is a virgin as a result. And not only that but because if she paints Edward as this sort of you know he's thinking about God and his mind is on higher things and all of that. I mean people yeah they're like oh brilliant but it sort of emphasizes that her family, Godwin and his sons have been the people who've actually been making the machine work and keeping England going. And so it makes them look good too.
这也将她与这种圣洁的贞洁项目联系在一起，因为由此推论，她也因此是一个处女。不仅如此，因为如果她把爱德华描绘成这样一种人——你知道的，他想着上帝，他的思想在更高的事情上诸如此类——我的意思是，人们会觉得，哦，太棒了，但这某种程度上强调了她的家族，戈德温和他的儿子们，才是真正让机器运转并维持英格兰前进的人。这也让他们看起来很棒。
Yes. So the life, even as it's celebrating Edward as this kind of otherworldly figure who spends his whole time hanging out with monks, it's emphasizing how Harold and Tostig are, and all his other brothers, he's got hundreds of brothers, how they are setting their shoulder to the wheel and laboring hard in the cause of England. And in fact, it's clear even from the life of King Edward that he's not spending his whole time with monks, even the life has to admit that actually he's spending most of his time hunting. Right. It's clear that Edward essentially has been sidelined, that he's become a bit
是的。因此，尽管这部传记颂扬爱德华是一个超脱世俗、把全部时间都用来和修士们混在一起的人物，但它强调了哈罗德和托斯蒂格，以及他所有的其他兄弟——他有上百个兄弟——是如何肩负重任、为英格兰的事业辛勤劳动的。事实上，即使从《爱德华国王生平》中也可以清楚地看出，他并非把所有时间都用来和修士们在一起，甚至连传记也不得不承认，实际上他把大部分时间都花在了打猎上。对。很明显，爱德华本质上已经被边缘化了，他已经变成了一个有点
of a cipher, but he's really not spending his whole time confessing. He's killing a lot of deer. And I think this sense of Edward that the life is promoting as a man almost kind of too good for the world is heightened by a dramatic development in 1053. And if people going into exile and coming back is one theme of this series then another is people at meals unexpectedly dying of choking fits. So this happens at Easter in 1053. Godwin is with the king in Winchester at a great Easter feast and he chokes to death. But there's no suspicion here of foul play, is there? I mean this just seems like an occupational hazard of are they just eating an enormous amount of
微不足道的人物，但他真的没有把所有时间都用来忏悔。他在杀很多鹿。我认为传记所宣扬的这种爱德华的形象——一个几乎好得不属于这个世界的人——在1053年的一次戏剧性事件中得到了强化。如果流放和回归是这个系列的一个主题，那么另一个主题就是在吃饭时意外因噎窒息死亡。这发生在1053年的复活节。戈德温和国王在温彻斯特参加一个盛大的复活节宴会时噎死了。但这里没有谋杀的嫌疑，对吧？我的意思是这看起来只是一种职业风险，难道他们只是吃了大量的
of like ill-cooked meat? Very tough meat. I mean, who knows? Yeah, I don't think there's any hint and it doesn't really alter Edward's position because he has no choice but to appoint Harold as Earl of Wessex. That's the moment where we began this series and I think actually it kind of makes him look even weaker because there's a sense of a generational shift. You know, this new generation of Earls, Harold and so on are stepping up to the plate. Right. And Edward looks kind of elderly and decrepit and bit out of the loop, but there is a bit of a balance of power thing going on here, isn't there? Because Harold had been Earl of East Anglia, but now he's taken over the kind of premier job, which is Earl of Wessex. So he's got the Heartland region, but he's replaced in East Anglia by a guy called Elfgar, who is the son of Leofric. So you've got Leofric
比如煮得不好的肉？非常硬的肉。我的意思是，谁知道呢？是的，我认为没有任何迹象，这并没有真正改变爱德华的立场，因为他别无选择，只能任命哈罗德为威塞克斯伯爵。那是我们开始这个系列的地方，而且我认为这实际上让他看起来更加虚弱，因为有一种代际更迭的感觉。你知道，这代新伯爵，哈罗德等等正在挺身而出。对。爱德华看起来有点年迈衰老，与世隔绝，但这里确实有一些权力平衡的事情在发生，对吧？因为哈罗德曾是东盎格利亚伯爵，但现在他接管了最重要的职位，也就是威塞克斯伯爵。所以他拥有核心地区，但在东盎格利亚，他被一个叫埃尔夫加的人取代了，他是莱夫里克之所以你有了莱夫里克
in Mercia, you've got Elfgar in East Anglia, you have this boat Seawood in Northumbria and Harold in Wessex. And Edward can kind of play them off against each other, presumably. You've got Elfgar in East Anglia, you have this book Seward in Northumbria and Harald in Wessex and Edward can kind of play them off against each other presumably, there's a bit of a balance. I'd agree, there's kind of balance of power there. But then in 1055, so that's only two years after the death of Godwin, there's another dramatic development because Seward dies, the Earl of Northumbria. People just keep dying in history, don't they?
在麦西亚，东盎格利亚有埃尔夫加，诺森布里亚有这个叫西沃德的人，威塞克斯有哈罗德。爱德华大概可以让他们互相制衡。你在东盎格利亚有埃尔夫加，诺森布里亚有这个叫西沃德的人，威塞克斯有哈罗德，爱德华大概可以让他们互相制衡，这有一点平衡。我同意，那里有一种权力平衡。但随后在1055年，也就是戈德温死后仅仅两年，又发生了一个戏剧性的事件，因为西沃德死了，诺森布里亚伯爵。历史总是有人不断死去，对吧？
It's an occupational hazard of being an 11th century Earl, I think. And the huge question is, who is going to succeed Seward as Earl of Northumbria? And Harold leans on Edward. Edith leans on Edward. And they persuade Edward to appoint to the vacant Eldom of Northumbria
我认为这是成为11世纪伯爵的职业风险。最大的问题是，谁将接替西沃德成为诺森布里亚伯爵？哈罗德向爱德华施压。埃迪特向爱德华施压。他们说服爱德华任命空缺的诺森布里亚伯爵职位
their brother Tostig. And the life of King Edward, unsurprisingly, thinks this is brilliant. Good news for Tostig, good news for Northumbria, good news for England. And it does acknowledge that Tostig is a bit shorter than Harald, but insists otherwise that he's quite as brave, quite as strong, quite as handsome as the absolute paragon
给他们的兄弟托斯蒂格。毫无疑问，《爱德华国王生平》认为这太棒了。对托斯蒂格是个好消息，对诺森布里亚是个好消息，对英格兰是个好消息。它确实承认托斯蒂格比哈罗德矮一点，但坚称他在其他方面同样勇敢、同样强壮、同样英俊，不亚于他那绝对堪称楷模的
that is his elder brother. Now the Godwins obviously think this is tremendous, but there are lots of people who are really opposed to Tostig becoming the Earl of Northumbria. So Elfgar, who is the son of Leofric, the Earl of Mercia, who's just been appointed the Earl of East Anglia, he has a massive strop. He briefly threatens a civil war, goes into exile, comes back, but Harold manages to patch things up with him. In the north, there's a lot of grumbling because northerners back then, I mean, it's no longer the case, but back then they didn't like southerners particularly.
大哥。戈德温家族显然认为这太棒了，但有很多人强烈反对托斯蒂格成为诺森布里亚伯爵。所以埃尔夫加，也就是麦西亚伯爵莱夫里克的儿子，刚刚被任命为东盎格利亚伯爵，他大发雷霆。他短暂地威胁要发动内战，流亡，然后回来，但哈罗德设法与他修好了关系。在北方，有很多抱怨，因为那里的北方人当时——我的意思是，现在已经不是这样了——但当时他们特别不喜欢南方人。
Yeah, I mean, that would never happen now. That would never happen now. And then in 1058, the Godwins are still on manoeuvres. So they don't really want Alfgar as Earl of East Anglia. So they elbow him aside and appoint another of Harold's brothers, Gyrth, to become the Earl of East Anglia. And Alfgar has another massive strop. Again, he goes into exile. Again, he comes back. Again, Harald patches things up. And there's this brilliant comment about it in the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle that listeners may well agree with. It is tedious to tell how
是的，我的意思是，现在绝不会发生这种事了。现在绝不会发生这种事了。然后在1058年，戈德温家族仍在进行政治运作。所以他们真的不想要埃尔夫加担任东盎格利亚伯爵。于是他们把他挤开，任命哈罗德的另一个兄弟格思担任东盎格利亚伯爵。埃尔夫加又大发雷霆。他又流亡了。他又回来了。哈罗德又一次修好了关系。盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史中对此有一段精彩的评论，听众们可能会深有同感。叙述这一切是如何发生的
it all happened. If we adopted that mantra, there'd be definitely no podcast. But essentially there is kind of festering resentment on the part of Leofric, Alfgar and Alfgar's sons, Edwin and Morkar. So this kind of this great dynasty in the middle of England and they don't like being sandwiched between two of the Godwin's sons, Harold in the south, Tostig in the north and now with the appointment of Girth, the the elder of East Anglia, to their east as well. And the life of King Edward obviously thinks it's fantastic. You know, it's wonderful that essentially England is pretty much now securely Godwin run and exclaims, and so with
真是令人厌烦。如果我们采用这个口号，就绝对没有播客了。但本质上，莱夫里克、埃尔夫加以及埃尔夫加的儿子们埃德温和莫卡心中有一种挥之不去的怨恨。所以英格兰中部这个强大的王朝不喜欢被戈德温的两个儿子夹在中间，南边是哈罗德，北边是托斯蒂格，现在随着东边任命格思为东盎格利亚伯爵。《爱德华国王生平》显然认为这太棒了。你知道，这太美妙了，基本上现在英格兰稳固地由戈德温家族掌控，它惊叹道，随着
the kingdom made safe on all sides by these nobles, the most kindly King Edward passed his life in security and peace. That's lovely, but obviously King Edward is not going to last forever. And there is this massive question mark about what happens if assuming, I mean, I think everyone's probably assumed by now, haven't they? He's never going to have a son to succeed him. He and Edith are never going to have children. So the question now is who comes next? Because everybody must be thinking this from the mid to late 1050s onwards. Right. And as the 1050s turned to the 1060s, the fame of Harold as a warrior grows. But
王国在这些贵族的保卫下四面稳固，最仁慈的爱德华国王在安全与和平中度过了他的一生。这很美好，但显然爱德华国王不会永远活着。关于假设——我的意思是，我想大家现在大概都假设了吧？他永远不会有一个儿子来继承他。他和埃迪特永远不会有孩子。所以现在的问题是谁来接替？因为从1050年代中期到后期开始，每个人肯定都在考虑这个问题。对。随着1050年代过渡到1060年代，哈罗德作为一名勇士的名声越来越大。但
so also across the channel is the fame of another great warrior, William the Duke of Normandy. The fame of Harold is complemented by that of William and the fame of William is complemented by that of Harold. And the sense of Harold is complemented by that of William and the fame of William is complemented by that of Harold and the sense of them is these two great models of warrior lords. People know what the implication of this is, you know, that there's the prospect of an almighty crash coming. So to look at Harold first, his record in the 1060s, in 1062 he launches a surprise attack on this guy called Gruffydd Apllwelyn, a prince who has made himself king pretty much the whole of Wales. That's a very rare occurrence. Wales is normally very kind of patchwork of rival princedoms. But this
同样，在海峡对岸，另一位伟大战士的名声也在增长，他就是诺曼底公爵威廉。哈罗德的名声与威廉的名声相辅相成，威廉的名声也与哈罗德的名声相辅相成。哈罗德的形象与威廉的形象相辅相成，威廉的形象也与哈罗德的形象相辅相成，他们俩作为勇士领主的两大模范的形象交织在一起。人们知道这意味着什么，你知道的，这意味着一场巨大的碰撞即将到来。所以先来看看哈罗德，他在1060年代的战绩，1062年他发动了一次突袭，攻击了一个叫格鲁菲德·阿普·利埃林的人，这是一个几乎将整个威尔士都变成自己王国的王子。这非常罕见。威尔士通常是由许多敌对诸侯国拼凑而成的。但这位
Gruffydd has made himself king of Wales and this is obviously seen by the English elites as a direct threat to them and Harold launches a surprise attack. Griffith is taken completely by surprise. He manages to escape, but the following year in 1063 he's cornered in the wilds of Snowdonia and decapitated and his head is sent to Harold who then sends it on to Edward the Confessor. Meanwhile across the channel, William has invaded and successfully annexed Maine, which people who listened to the previous episode may remember is
格鲁菲德让自己成为了威尔士国王，这在英格兰精英阶层看来显然是对他们的直接威胁，于是哈罗德发动了突袭。格鲁菲德完全措手不及。他设法逃脱了，但在第二年，即1063年，他在斯诺多尼亚的荒野中被逼入绝境并被斩首，他的头颅被送给了哈罗德，哈罗德随后又将其转送给忏悔者爱德华。与此同时，在海峡对岸，威廉入侵并成功吞并了曼恩，听过上一集的听众可能还记得，那是
the kind of the the border zone between Normandy and the great county of Anjou, the the Normans deadliest enemy really. And William has done this in a very brutal and effective way. And a chronicler in praise of William says, terror was sown across the land. And the consequence of this is that William now has nothing to fear from his southern flank. Right. So he can look northwards.
诺曼底与安茹大伯爵领地之间的缓冲地带，安茹人可以说是诺曼人最致命的敌人。威廉以一种非常残酷且有效的方式做到了这一点。一位赞美威廉的编年史家写道：“恐惧播撒在整个土地上。”其结果是，威廉现在不用担心他的南翼了。对。所以他可以把目光投向北方。
He can be thinking about what happens in England. Yes, he absolutely can. And so finally, we come to this moment, one of the most famous moments, not just of this whole story, but in all English medieval history. So either in 1064 or in 1065, Harold and William at last come face to face. And it's the very first episode that you see on the Bayer tapestry, you know, one of the most famous, I was about to say one of the most famous documents, I mean, I guess it is a document of a kind, one of
他可以考虑英格兰会发生什么。是的，他绝对可以。因此，最后我们来到了这个时刻，不仅是整个故事中，也是整个英国中世纪历史中最著名的时刻之一。所以在1064年或1065年，哈罗德和威廉终于面对面了。这是你在巴约挂毯上看到的第一个场景，你知道的，最著名的之一，我正要说最著名的文件之一，我的意思是，我想它确实算是一种文件，最著名的文件之一，
the most famous documents, not just in English history, but in all history. So Tom, tell us how Harold and William finally get to meet. So as you say, I mean, it is, it is shown on the Bayer Tapestry and there are normal accounts, there are English accounts, there are English accounts. The Norman and English accounts often differ quite radically on the spin and interpretation they put on the episode. But I think the basic outline is clear. Essentially, Harold sets sail at Southwoods. Why?
不仅在英国历史中，在所有历史中都是如此。那么，汤姆，给我们讲讲哈罗德和威廉是如何最终相遇的。如你所说，我的意思是，它确实被描绘在巴约挂毯上，有诺曼人的记载，也有英国人的记载。诺曼人和英国人的记载在对这一事件的润色和解释上往往截然不同。但我认为基本轮廓是清晰的。本质上，哈罗德从索思伍兹起航。为什么？
The Beowat tapestry and the Norman historians insist that he has been sent by Edward to promise William the succession. The English insist that he has been sent by Edward to promise William the succession. The English insist that he traveled there of his own volition in order to negotiate a marriage alliance or the release of some hostages of his own family, some of his brothers who have been kept by William. William of Malmesbury, the Dominic Sandbrook of the 12th century, who's very, very patriotic, suggests that Harold had been blown off course while on a fishing trip. Yeah, that sounds the most plausible to me.
巴约挂毯和诺曼历史学家坚称他是被爱德华派去向威廉承诺王位继承权的。英国人坚称他是被爱德华派去向威廉承诺继承权的。英国人坚称他是出于自愿前往那里，目的是协商一桩婚姻同盟，或者释放他家族的一些人质，即威廉扣押的一些他的兄弟。12世纪的多米尼克·桑德布鲁克、那位非常非常爱国的威廉·马姆斯伯里暗示，哈罗德是在钓鱼时被风吹离航线的。是的，这对我来说听起来最合理。
So anyway, what happens then is that whatever reason Harold is sailing southwards across the channel, he's shipwrecked and he's taken prisoner by a local princeling. William secures his release. Harold becomes William's guest. He joins him on a campaign against the Bretons, the kind of the milk drinking barbarians of Brittany. And he watches the Normans in action. He watches their cavalry. He watches them build their castles. He is able to see their military operations up close. And when they're not fighting, William and Harold are talking geopolitics. And it's evident that Harold, who is very charming, very proficient in making people like him,
所以无论如何，接下来发生的是，不管哈罗德向南横渡海峡的原因是什么，他遭遇海难并被当地一个小诸侯俘虏。威廉确保了他获释。哈罗德成了威廉的客人。他加入了威廉针对布列塔尼人（布列塔尼的那些喝奶的野蛮人）的战役。他观察诺曼人作战。他观察他们的骑兵。他观察他们建造城堡。他能够近距离观察他们的军事行动。在不打仗的时候，威廉和哈罗德会谈论地缘政治。很明显，哈罗德非常迷人，非常擅长让人喜欢他，
gets William to talk about his ambitions. William talks about how he feels he has this right to the English throne. He wants to press it. He absolutely believes that Edward has promised him the throne and Harold then swears an oath on the bones of saints that he will uphold William's claim to the English throne. And again, Norman historians insist he does this because Edward has sent him to do it. Yeah, because he was always going to do it. An English historian say that basically he couldn't see any way of escape without agreeing to all that William wished.
他让威廉谈论他的野心。威廉谈到他觉得他对英格兰王位有这种权利。他想争取它。他坚信爱德华向他承诺过王位，然后哈罗德在圣人遗骨上起誓，他将维护威廉对英格兰王位的权利。诺曼历史学家再次坚称他是这么做的，因为爱德华派他这么做了。是的，因为他本来就要这么做。而英国历史学家则说，基本上他想不出任何逃脱的办法，只能同意威廉的所有愿望。
William basically forces him to do it. Yes. Well, he doesn't have any other way of getting back. Otherwise he'll be a kind of hostage in Normandy. So he does this. He swears to uphold Williams right to the English throne. And he is then given a Norman ship. It's loaded down with gifts and Harold sails back to England.
威廉基本上迫使他这么做了。是的。好吧，他没有别的办法回去了。否则他就会成为诺曼底的人质。所以他照做了。他发誓要维护威廉对英格兰王位的权利。然后他得到了一艘诺曼船。船上装满了礼物，哈罗德起航回到了英格兰。
And so the huge question hanging over this is, you know, what is the truth? What had Harold been up to? And Edward A Freeman, the Regents Professor of Oxford in the 19th century, who wrote again a kind of Sandbrookian six volume history of the Norman conquest. He said of this, it is one of the most perplexing questions in all history. I don't know whether you agree with that. He's not wrong. So here's the thing, right?
因此，悬在这个问题之上的巨大疑问是，你知道，真相是什么？哈罗德一直在干什么？19世纪牛津大学的摄政教授爱德华·A·弗里曼曾写过一部关于诺曼征服的桑德布鲁克式的六卷本历史，他对此评论道：“这是整个历史中最令人困惑的问题之一。”我不知道你是否同意这一点。他说得没错。所以问题是，对吧？
I think you and I probably agree on this and we agree, Will, so with other recent historians. So for example, Mark Morris, who's written about the Norman Conquest and the end of Anglo Sex in England. It's just utterly implausible that Harold, who is so powerful and rich and such a serious player, would have meekly crossed the channel in response to Edward the Confessor's instructions to swear allegiance to the Duke of Normandy. I mean, that just seems absolutely unbelievable, doesn't it, Tom? I agree. But then, of course, there is the question of why does why does he go you know and the claim of English historians that he's going to
我想你和我可能对此有共识，威廉，我们也和其他近期的历史学家看法一致。例如，马克·莫里斯，他写过关于诺曼征服和盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰终结的书。哈罗德如此强大、富有且是一个如此严肃的政治玩家，怎么会仅仅因为忏悔者爱德华的指示，就温顺地横渡海峡去向诺曼底公爵效忠呢？这简直太不可信了，对吧，汤姆？我同意。但随后，当然，问题是为什么——为什么他要去看——你知道的，英国历史学家宣称他是去
negotiate the release of his brothers I mean it's perfectly possible. Yeah there are historians who think that who say if he wanted to succeed then having these hostages at the Norman Court would have been a massive time bomb so he wants to get them back but also it's humiliating for his family to have hostages at the Norman court. Yeah, so there is that. But I think, I still don't think that is adequate to explain why he would put himself in such a risky situation.
协商释放他的兄弟们，我的意思是，这完全有可能。是的，有些历史学家是这么认为的，他们说如果他想继承王位，在诺曼底宫廷里有人质将是一个巨大的定时炸弹，所以他想把他们弄回来，而且让家族人质留在诺曼底宫廷也是一种羞辱。是的，确实有这种说法。但我仍然认为，这不足以解释他为什么要把自己置于如此危险的境地。
And I think the answer is, again, is to be found in the life of King Edward, full of gems and riches. And it gives an account of a pilgrimage that Harold made to Rome kind of earlier in the 1050s, which very clearly simultaneously served as a kind of espionage mission. So to quote the life of King Edward, he studied the character, policy and strength of the princes of Gaul, not only through his servants, but in person and adroitly and with natural cunning and with lengthy and intent observation. So that's not written about Harold's trip to Normandy. The life of King Edward doesn't really mention that.
我认为答案同样可以在《爱德华国王生平》中找到，这本书充满了珍宝和财富。它记载了哈罗德在1050年代早期前往罗马的朝圣之旅，这非常明显地同时充当了一种间谍任务。引用《爱德华国王生平》的话说：“他不仅通过仆人，而且亲自研究了高卢诸侯的性格、政策和实力，凭借其敏锐、天生的狡猾以及漫长而专注的观察。”这并不是写哈罗德的诺曼底之行的。《爱德华国王生平》并没有真正提及这一点。
But it's clear that this is part of Harold's policy. He believes in good intelligence. And I suppose because he rates his own powers of observation, he wants to see it for himself. Right. And I suspect that he's going to get try and get his his brothers back. But above all, he's doing it because he wants to spy out the Norman way of war. Most people in England have no awareness of the kind of military revolution that is occurring. But Harold obviously does because he's been to France and he's seen it. And he wants
但很明显，这是哈罗德政策的一部分。他相信情报的重要性。我想，因为他对自己的观察力很有信心，所以他想亲自去看看。对。我怀疑他是想去尝试把他的兄弟们接回来。但最重要的是，他这样做是因为他想刺探诺曼人的战争方式。英格兰大多数人对正在发生的军事革命一无所知。但哈罗德显然知道，因为他去过法国并亲眼目睹了。他想
to see how this revolution is operating specifically in the context of Normandy. He wants to see how the Duke's castles are built, the aggressive use to which they can be put, the potential of the Norman cavalry. And the problem for Harold, of course, is that to extract himself from this spy mission, he does clearly have to swear this oath. I mean everyone essentially English as well as Norman accept this. But I guess he would say, you know, needs must. And again, there is a wonderful phrase in the life of King Edward about Harold, which reads so true that it was his way ever, the life of King Edward says, to pass with watchful mockery through every ambush. I love that. I love that phrase. Watchful mockery should be our watchword on this podcast.
看看这场革命是如何具体在诺曼底的语境下运作的。他想看看公爵的城堡是如何建造的，它们可以被如何激进地使用，以及诺曼骑兵的潜力。当然，对哈罗德来说，问题在于为了从这次间谍任务中脱身，他显然必须发誓。我的意思是，每个人——无论是英国人还是诺曼人都基本上承认这一点。但我想他会说，你知道的，时势逼人嘛。《爱德华国王生平》中关于哈罗德有一句精彩的话，听起来是如此真实，书中说，这永远是他的风格，“带着警惕的嘲弄穿过每一个伏击”。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这句话。“警惕的嘲弄”应该成为我们这个播客的座右铭。
I mean, that's basically what we do. Well, good for Harold. I think he's come out of this splendidly. Even though he's sworn an oath on the bones of saints, which he has no intention of keeping. Tom, I mean, have I ever struck you in all the years of doing this podcast as a man who cares about oaths sworn on the bones of saints? I think I'm more the kind of person who would worry about an oath sworn on the bones of saints. I'm more the watchful mockery.
我的意思是，这基本上就是我们在做的。好吧，干得好，哈罗德。我觉得他在这件事上表现得很出色。尽管他在圣骨上发了誓，而他根本没打算遵守。汤姆，我的意思是，在做这个播客的所有年头里，我有没有给你留下过一个关心在圣骨上发誓的人的印象？我想我更那种会担心在圣骨上发誓的人。我更倾向于警惕的嘲弄。
I enjoy a bit of watchful mockery. I mean, I do think this is potentially a massive, massive issue for Harold that he under appreciates because while he's clearly aware of this great military revolution that is brewing in France, I think he underplays the extent to which there is a moral religious revolution happening as well. I like him more and more. That's great. Yeah, but it's poor intelligence, as we will see in due course, because it doesn't help his case, I think. Anyway, but we will be coming to that. And I think clearly what it means, the fact that he has sworn this oath and he's now presumably preparing to break it, it means that if he does become king, then invasion is inevitable. So why is Harold
我喜欢来点警惕的嘲弄。我的意思是，我确实认为这可能对哈罗德是一个巨大、巨大的问题，而他低估了这一点，因为虽然他显然意识到法国正在酝酿的这场伟大的军事革命，但我认为他低估了同时发生的道德宗教革命的程度。我越来越喜欢他了。太棒了。是的，但正如我们日后将看到的，这是糟糕的情报，因为它对他的案件没有帮助，我想。无论如何，我们会谈到那一点。而且我认为很明显这意味着，鉴于他发了誓而且现在大概正准备违背它，这意味着如果他真的成了国王，那么入侵是不可避免的。那么为什么哈罗德
prepared to risk it? Well, he is not the only powerful figure, obviously, from his family in England. There is also his brother Tostec, who commands the Northern Marches. And the life of King Edward again celebrates this pairing, the two great brothers in very, very inspirational tones. Two great brothers of a cloud-born land, the kingdom sacred oaks, with joined strength and like agreement, they guard the bounds of England. What could possibly go wrong?
准备冒这个险呢？好吧，显然他在英格兰不是唯一的权势人物。还有他的兄弟托斯蒂格，他统领着北方边境。而《爱德华国王生平》再次以非常非常鼓舞人心的语气歌颂了这对搭档，这两位伟大的兄弟。云端之地的两位伟大兄弟，王国的神圣橡树，以齐心协力和一致的契约，守护着英格兰的边界。能出什么差错呢？
Right, well, it does go wrong, doesn't it? So we get to 1065. Howard is obviously thinking, you know, the clock is ticking now. Edward the Confessor is old and he's ill, so the end could well be coming. And Harold has obviously got his eyes fixed on the English Channel thinking, you know, if it all kicks off, needs to make preparations. But to some extent, maybe he's turned his back on and forgotten what's been going on in the north of England, because in the north where Tostig is in charge, things are not
好吧，确实出差错了，对吧？所以我们到了1065年。哈罗德显然在想，你知道的，时间不多了。忏悔者爱德华又老又病，所以末日很可能就要降临了。哈罗德的目光显然紧盯着英格兰海峡，心想，如果局势爆发，必须做好准备。但在某种程度上，也许他已经把背转向了英格兰北方，忘记了那里发生的事情，因为在托斯蒂格管辖的北方，情况并不
good are they? Right. So the north is a pretty tough place to keep in order. It's poorer than the south. It's notoriously violent. So according to the life of King Edward, travelling parties of people up to 20 or 30 are regularly being kind of ambushed, robbed, murdered. You have the King of Scotland who's an increasingly menacing presence beyond the border. And even the women in Northumbria
好，对吧？对。所以北方是一个很难维持秩序的地方。它比南方穷。以暴力闻名。因此，根据《爱德华国王生平》，多达20或30人的旅行团经常遭到伏击、抢劫、谋杀。苏格兰国王是一个在边境之外越来越具有威胁性的存在，甚至连诺森布里亚的女人
think nothing of sticking the heads of captured Scotsmen on poles. So it's a frightening, intimidating place if you're from the South. I mean, very different today, obviously. And I think because of this, because Tostig, who's been raised in the South, essentially sees it as a terrifying place full of intimidating women and Scotsmen and all kinds of horrors. Essentially, he doesn't go there very often and he leaves his own placement to organize it and run it for him. And it prevents him from forging the kind of personal links that an earl needs to have. And his character also is not as charming, he's not as adroit, he's not as kind of calculating, I think, as either
也毫不犹豫地把抓到的苏格兰人的脑袋插在杆子上。所以如果你来自南方，那是一个可怕、令人胆寒的地方。我的意思是，今天当然大不相同了。我想正因为如此，因为托斯蒂格在南方长大，基本上把那里看作是一个充满了令人畏惧的女人、苏格兰人和各种恐怖的可怕地方。基本上，他并不经常去那里，而是留下他自己的亲信来组织和管理。这使他无法建立一个伯爵所需要的人际联系。而且他的性格也没有他
his elder brother Harold or his father Godwin. And even the life of King Edward admits this, so it writes, renowned for his courage and cunning but also possessed of an often fiery temper, he had tended to respond to hints of restiveness with all the forcefulness he could muster. And to make matters worse he's put taxes up hasn't he? So people are not happy about that. Yeah and the problem is that he's putting up taxes as the service that he's providing as an Earl is going into rapid decline, because the King of Scotland, Malcolm, so as in Macbeth, the King who has succeeded Macbeth, you know, he can send opportunity. them. Scottish raids are becoming more and more regular and more and more punitive. So Lindisfarne, the Holy Island where Cuthbert had been the abbot, that gets sacked. Cumbria is annexed. By the Scots, Craig.
的大哥哈罗德或父亲戈德温那样迷人、精明或善于算计。甚至连《爱德华国王生平》也承认这一点，所以它写道：“以勇气和狡猾闻名，但也常常脾气火暴，他往往倾向于用他所能调集的所有武力来回应任何不安的迹象。”更糟糕的是他还加了税，对吧？所以人们对此很不高兴。是的，问题在于，随着他作为伯爵提供的服务在迅速衰退，他还在加税，因为苏格兰国王马尔科姆——就像《麦克白》里取代了麦克白的那位国王一样——他看到了机会。苏格兰人的袭击变得越来越频繁，也越来越具有惩罚性。所以林迪斯法恩，圣徒卡斯伯特曾担任住持的圣岛，被洗劫了。坎布里亚被苏格兰人
By the Scots. And I mean, this is infuriating for the Northumbrians. Yeah. You know, they're having to pay all these taxes and yet the Scots are endlessly coming down and kind of, you know, looting them and killing them and it's not good. And had Tostig been in Northumbria more often, he would have been able to read the runes. I mean, literally, because there's quite a lot of runes up there. Oh, Tom, that's a great metaphor. Well done. But he doesn't. And as a result, on the 3rd of October, 1065, a group of rebels against Tostig's rule wipe out his placement in York
吞并了。被苏格兰人吞并。我的意思是，这让诺森布里亚人愤怒不已。是的。你知道，他们不得不支付所有这些税款，然而苏格兰人却不断南下进行掠夺和杀戮，这可不好。如果托斯蒂格更常去诺森布里亚，他就能读懂那些符文了。字面意义上的，因为那里有很多符文。哦，汤姆，这是一个绝妙的比喻。干得好。但他没有。结果，在1065年10月3日，一群反对托斯蒂格统治的叛军在约克消灭了他的心腹并
and capture the city. He's taken completely by surprise. He has no idea that this was coming. And it's evident from what then happens that this conspiracy has been very carefully planned, very carefully coordinated. And so Tostig's adherents across Northumbria are targeted for elimination and the Northumbrians proclaim as their new Earl, a son of Alfgar, so that's the grandson of Leofric, the Earl of Mercia, and this is a guy called Morkar. And I mean Morkar is a Mercian, he has nothing to do with Northumbria, but clearly the rebels in Northumbria have decided that the dynasty of Leofric is the only one that can kind of basically go toe to toe with the Godwins. Isn't there an interesting shadow story here in the Norman Conquest? Which is, we always
攻占了这座城市。他完全措手不及。他根本不知道这一切会发生。从接下来发生的事情中可以明显看出，这场阴谋经过了非常仔细的策划和协调。因此，托斯蒂格在整个诺森布里亚的支持者都成了被消灭的目标，诺森布里亚人拥立了一个新伯爵，即埃尔夫加的儿子，也就是麦西亚伯爵莱夫里克的孙子，这个人叫莫卡。我的意思是莫卡是个麦西亚人，他与诺森布里亚毫无关系，但很明显，诺森布里亚的叛军已经决定，莱夫里克家族是唯一一个能够基本上与戈德温家族分庭抗礼的王朝。诺曼征服中难道没有一个有趣的暗线故事吗？那就是，我们总
think of it as kind of Normans versus Anglo-Saxons and Danes, but actually there's this rivalry between these two families, the family of Leofric and the family of Godwin, that runs through, I mean we're talking about decades of English history leading up to the Norman Conquest. And it's quite subterranean I think in the sources. But when you look for it you see it everywhere and definitely this is what's happening here. So down south, Harold and Tostig are with their sister and King Edward in Wilton. So again, Wilton in the Salisbury area. Lovely to get the Salisbury area in. The centre of action where they've assembled for the dedication of Edith's great stone
认为它是诺曼人对阵盎格鲁-撒克逊人和丹麦人，但实际上这两个家族之间存在着竞争，即莱夫里克家族和戈德温家族，贯穿其中——我的意思是我们在谈论的是导致诺曼征服的几十年的英国历史。我认为这在史料中相当隐秘。但当你寻找它时，你会发现它无处不在，这绝对就是这里正在发生的事情。在南方，哈罗德和托斯蒂格与他们的姐姐和爱德华国王在威尔顿。再次强调，威尔顿在索尔兹伯里地区。很高兴把索尔兹伯里地区扯进来。他们聚集在那里，为埃迪特一直在建造的巨大石质修道院举行落成典礼，作为威斯敏斯特修道院的对照。哈罗德立即向北骑马，试图与埃德温、莫卡以及诺森布里亚叛军进行谈判，因为此时他们已经合兵一处并正向南进军，哈罗德在北安普顿与叛军会面，叛军说我们再也不要托斯蒂格当伯爵了，剥夺他的权力，把他流放出英国，他是个混蛋，我们不想要他。哈罗德拼命想救他的兄弟，我认为这毫无疑问，但叛军根本不听。于是哈罗德回到爱德华身边，爱德华仍然在索尔兹伯里地区的一个名叫布里特福德的村庄里，我一个学校朋友就住在那里。哈罗德
abbey that she's been building as a parallel to Westminster Abbey. And Harold immediately rides north to try and negotiate with Edwin and Moorke and the Northumbrian rebels because by this point they've all joined forces and they're marching southwards and Harold meets with the rebels at Northampton and the rebels say we're not going to have Tostig anymore as Earl, strip him of his powers, exile him from England, he's a shocker, we don't want him. And Harold desperately tries to save his brother, I don't think there's any doubt about that, but the rebels are having none of it. And so Harold returns to Edward, who is still in the Salisbury area at a place called a village called Britford, where one of my friends from school lived. And Harold
说，听着，情况不太妙。我真的很抱歉。我想托斯蒂格不得不走了。托斯蒂格对此愤怒至极，疯狂地认为哈罗德也参与了这场阴谋。我的意思是，他彻底失控了，要求哈罗德集结威塞克斯的民兵，去对抗埃德温、莫卡以及诺森布里亚人。但哈罗德拒绝了，你知道的，哈罗德绝不可能这么做。这对英格兰来说将是致命的，对戈德温家族来说也将是致命的，对他成为英格兰国王的前景来说同样是致命的。
says, look, it's not looking good. I'm really sorry. I think Tostig is going to have to go. And Tostig is furious about this and madly thinks that Harold is in on the conspiracy as well. I mean, he's completely lost it and demands that Harold raise the, you know, the levies of Wessex and goes to oppose Edwin and more current than Northumbrians. But Harold, no, you know, there's no way Harold can do this. It would be fateful for England, but it would obviously be fateful for the Godwinson's and it would be fateful for his prospects as becoming King of England.
是的。而且他当然也知道威廉正潜伏在海峡对岸。所以他拒绝了，托斯蒂格别无选择，只能流放。因此在11月1日，他、他的妻子和他的家臣离开英格兰前往法兰德斯流放，托斯蒂格的妻子是法兰德斯伯爵的女儿，所以他（你知道的）大概可以在那里受到欢迎。这个完全出乎意料、如同晴天霹雳般的内部决裂带来的震惊，对爱德华产生了非常不好的影响，他的健康恶化，身体开始衰弱。因此，随着1065年接近尾声，1066年在地平线上隐约浮现，爱德华看起来越来越接近死亡。
Yeah. And he knows, of course, also that William is lurking across the channel. So he refuses and Tostig has no choice but to go into exile. So first of November, he, his wife, his thanes leave England for exile in Flanders and Tostig's wife is a daughter of the Count of Flanders. So he, you know, he can kind of expect a welcome there. And the shock of this, there's this completely unexpected kind of bust up has come from, you know, lightning from a clear blue sky has a very bad effect on Edward whose health worsens, he goes into a decline. And so as the year 1065 draws to
多米尼克，这就是我们结束这个系列的地方，但有各种各样的问题悬而未决。新年会带来爱德华的死吗？如果会，谁将成为英格兰的新国王？哈罗德？威廉？还是可能是完全的另一个人？好吧，我们下周将带着一个新系列回归，一个两部分组成的系列，将目光投向北方，我们将探讨那个“另一个人”。我们将讲述维京世界产生过的最惊险、最恐怖、最迷人的那个男人的故事。
a close and the year 1066 starts looming on the horizon, Edward increasingly seems near death. And this is the point Dominic, at which we end this series, but with all kinds of questions hanging in the air. Will the new year bring Edward's death? If it does, who will become England's new King? Harold? William? Or perhaps someone entirely else. Well, we will be back next week with a new series, a two part series, looking north and we'll be looking at that somebody else. We will be telling the story of, I think, the most thrilling, the most terrifying and the most glamorous man that the Viking world ever produced will
随着1066年的临近，爱德华越来越显得濒临死亡。多米尼克，我们的系列节目也正是在这个时候结束，但各种问题依然悬念重重。新的一年会带来爱德华的死吗？如果是的话，谁将成为英格兰的新国王？哈罗德？威廉？或者可能是完全另一个人。好吧，我们下周将推出一个新系列，一个两部分的系列，将目光投向北方，我们来看看那个“另一个人”。我们将讲述我认为是维京世界产生过的最惊心动魄、最恐怖、最迷人的男人的故事，将
be going to Norway, to Eastern Europe, to Kiev, to Constantinople as we follow the life and adventures of the last of the Vikings, Harald Hardrada. And you can, of course, hear both of those episodes at once by signing up to the Rest Is History Club at therestishistory.com. That's right, Dominic. And then when we've done that, we will be back with the story of 1066 itself, the invasion led by Harold Hardrada and then the invasion led by William Duke of Normandy.
前往挪威、东欧、基辅、君士坦丁堡，我们将追随最后一位维京人哈拉尔·哈德拉达的一生与冒险。当然，您只需登录 therestishistory.com 加入 The Rest Is History 俱乐部，就可以同时收听这两集节目。没错，多米尼克。然后当我们完成这些之后，我们将回归 1066 年本身的故事情节，即由哈拉尔·哈德拉达领导的入侵，以及随后由诺曼底公爵威廉领导的入侵。
So lots more to come. But in the meanwhile, thanks very much for listening. Bye bye. Goodbye. So here's a clip from our series on the troubles. This is the strangest thing about this story is that Northern Ireland is so small. And listen, there are other I mean, you could tell a similar story about Sarajevo or any number of other types of places where there's been a conflict, Rwanda, and then the conflict ends and everybody still
所以还有更多内容即将推出。但与此同时，非常感谢您的收听。再见。再见。那么，以下是我们关于北爱尔兰冲突系列节目的一个片段。这个故事最奇怪的地方在于北爱尔兰是如此之小。听着，还有其他——我的意思是，你可以讲述一个类似的故事，关于萨拉热窝或任何经历过冲突的其他地方，比如卢旺达，然后冲突结束了，每个人仍然
kind of lives in the same community and you see these people. But you know, there's an instance even as adults where Helen McConville was with her own family in McDonald's and sees one of the people who abducted her mother. There's a moment that I describe in the book where Michael McConville actually gets into the back of a black taxi in Belfast as an adult and he sees in the mirror in the front of the taxi, he realizes that the man driving him is one of the people who decades earlier abducted his mother. And the strangest, most eerie aspect of this is he doesn't say anything. And he doesn't even know if that guy recognizes
某种程度上生活在同一个社区里，你会看到这些人。但你知道，甚至在成年后，也有这样的例子：海伦·麦康维尔和她的家人在麦当劳时，看到了绑架她母亲的人之一。我在书中描述了一个时刻，成年后的迈克尔·麦康维尔实际上坐进了一辆在贝尔法斯特的黑色出租车的后座，他从出租车前面的后视镜里看到，他意识到开车的人就是几十年前绑架他母亲的人之一。而最奇怪、最诡异的方面是，他什么也没说。他甚至不知道那个人是否认出
him and they drive in silence and then he just pays the guy's money and leaves. To hear the full series, just search Empire wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
了他，他们默默地开着车，然后他付了车费就离开了。要收听完整系列节目，只需在您获取播客的任何地方搜索 Empire。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。